good morning believe nation today's
message is be comfortable with who you
are over to you Salma Hayek you should
not wait for someone else's opinion to
decide who you are it's nice if
somebody's supportive of you and
embracive of you but you should be
comfortable with who you are and come to
terms with who you are regardless of
others people's acceptance because then
it's you giving the power to the other
person ah this one said I was I was the
terrible oh I'm terrible he thinks I'm
terrible oh why does he think I'm
terrible I'm good I'm not and then
somebody else comes it's not you know
terrible okay I'm not terrible because
the other one says you're not terrible
so you're again waiting for someone else
to tell you who you are or what you are
or what you're supposed to be what
you're supposed to feel good about what
you are who you are it should not be
healed because somebody else likes you
it should be healed because you believe
something good about yourself so what
the other person thinks of you should
not matter as much focus on yourself on
improving yourself or being a good
person yourself focus on you liking
yourself do you like who you are be the
best that you can be and do not try to
be like anyone else I really love this
message and for me this is one of those
things that is super easy to love and
super easy to agree with but difficult
to execute I think most people who watch
this clip would agree that yes I want to
be comfortable with me I want to live my
life and not always worry about being
judged by others I think people want to
do that but the execution is hard all of
our lives we're we're trained to seek
acceptance and approval right when we're
really young we want to
parents to give us approval and see we
did a good job and as we go through
school we want you know our teachers to
give us an A and get their recognition
and we get the awards in the metal and
so we're trained to want to fit in be a
part of the club get acceptance and warm
feelings and we want people to tell us
that we're doing a good job and I think
that's dangerous and data can really
weaken your confidence in that when you
want to do something that's different
that's outside the norm and when people
don't support you it makes it really
hard to to try and keep going and you
might start for a little bit and then
stop and start and stop again I think
the people who do make the breakthroughs
the people who really take charge of
their own life to people who really
truly don't care make a decision at some
point that they're gonna live their
version of their life and not someone
else's are you doing this whatever it is
you're doing your career your
relationship whatever it is are you
doing it because you're trying to make
somebody else happy or you're trying to
make yourself happy and it doesn't mean
you have to be super selfish and only
think of yourself because what you do
Kayne's serve others can help others can
give back you can be a valuable part of
your community but the reason why you're
doing is because it makes you come alive
because you decided that this is
something that I want to do to not be an
accountant or a doctor or lawyer because
that's what your parents want to be if
you want to go be that that's great but
you're not doing it because there's
family pressures for you to have to do
that and so I know it's hard and I know
it's tough but when you see those people
make that decision that I'm gonna live
my version of my life and not somebody
else's version that's when you start to
see massive transformation that's when
you start to see people do a total 180
on their life and you start to see
explosive growth and you start to
finally come alive and you start to
finally be excited and happy and things
start falling into place and you don't
go to bed hating your life anymore but
it doesn't happen until you make the
commitment to yourself that this is your
life that you're gonna live and I
appreciate the people around me and
appreciate the advices are trying to
give but I'm doing it for me
I'm not doing it because of that so the
question today today is I'm curious what
prevents you from being comfortable with
who you are leave it in the comments
below and hopefully we can all help each
other out thank you guys so much for
watching having a
amazing they continue to believe and
I'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of espresso